Безпосередньо "купити" громадянство можна
в двох острівних країнах ЄС - на Кіпрі та Мальті.
У більшості інших - "купується" посвідка
на проживання, що потім полегшує отримання громадянства.
Тут діє так звана схема "золотої візи".
Достатньо вкласти два мільйони євро в нерухомість
або 2,5 мільйони в державні цінні папери
або в кіпрські компанії. При цьому не потрібно
здавати мовні тести або постійно проживати на острові.
Підданство цієї країни можна отримати, сплативши
650000 євро до Фонду національного розвитку.
Згідно з прейскурантом, за дружину або чоловіка
доведеться доплатити ще 25 тисяч євро, і стільки ж
за кожну неповнолітню дитину.
Крім того, заявник зобов'язується купити
нерухомість на Мальті не менше,
ніж за 350 тисяч євро, або ж орендувати житло
з мінімальною річною оплатою в 16 тисяч євро.
Отримати дозвіл на проживання в Іспанії можливо,
придбавши нерухомість за 500 тисяч євро.
Або ж купивши іспанські держоблігації за 2 млн євро,
чи  вклавши мільйон в приватні компанії
та інвестиційні фонди.
Схожа схема діє і в Португалії. Купивши житлову
або комерційну нерухомість за півмільйона євро,
ви отримуєте посвідку на проживання на пільгових умовах.
Ви також гарантовано її отримуєте,
інвестувавши мільйон євро в економіку країни.
Посвідка на проживання дає майже ті ж права, що і
громадянство, за винятком права обирати і бути обраним.
Греція в цьому плані трохи дешевша.
Потрібно купити нерухомість щонайменше за 250 тисяч євро.
Після цього ви та члени вашої родини автоматично
отримуєте посвідку на проживання.
Грецький паспорт можна отримати
після семи років проживання в країні.
А ось в Угорщині для отримання посвідки на проживання
досить купити облігації державної позики на 300 тисяч євро.
При цьому Будапешт обіцяє стовідсоткове
повернення інвестицій через 5 років.
Це головна відмінність порівняно з іншими країнами.
Щоправда, ще доведеться заплатити адміністративний збір
у 60 тисяч євро - для покриття витрат
на оформлення і супровід справи.
В Австрії також діє спеціальна програма
для заможних іноземців.
Інвестувавши в економіку країни, ви можете прискорено
отримати громадянство. Крім того, там ухвалили закон,
що дозволяє уряду надавати громадянство особам,
"які внесли або потенційно готові внести
надзвичайний внесок в особливих інтересах республіки".